this episode of The Mentalist is brought
to you by nobody
because advertisements suck and
minimalists hello simpletons
welcome to the minimalist podcast we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists one of our favorite people
on earth is here today we role is in the
studio rich thank you for being a
brother great to be here man thanks for
having me we call our our audience
simpletons because we're all a little
bit foolish and gullible so Ryan and I
are the head for yourself well we're the
head simpletons right we are actually
the simpletons we just dressed it up by
calling ourselves minimalist that was
actually my idea for the website before
we came up with the minimalist to the
simpletons calm he's too kind rich is
our returning champion I think this is
your fourth or fifth time on the podcast
yeah really really grateful today well
the world is ever changing and is
changing so fast that it's often hard to
find balance contentment or tranquility
so we're gonna talk about some different
stuff we would you should talk to you
about although I'm sure will circle
around many of the things that we've at
least touched upon in the past today
we're gonna theorize on what our new
normal will look like after this storm
and we're going to do that with with
just some questions that we have from
our audience I want to call this a new
abnormal because I don't think we're
gonna go back to a an exact replica of
where we were six months ago yeah I
don't I don't like the term new normal
yeah
I would like to dispense with the word
normal altogether right I think it's you
know I like to look at it through the
lens of opportunity like this is an
opportunity to change and to reimagine
broken systems and to you know really
get granular on what works and what
doesn't and our own personal lives and
you know politically socially everything
like let's not let this moment pass
without ceasing it do just that yeah
and so when I say abnormally I got the
title from the new strokes album is
called the new abnormal and and abnormal
can be a very good thing like Ryan's and
my life is a bit weird compared to the
status quo your life is weird compared
to the status quo but you've also been
through that status quo right I have
yeah but it's what it's also weird how
you acclimate to your status quo like I
lose sight of the fact that my status
quo is so distinct and different from
the average person's daily life like you
just you our ability to to normalize
everything around us and then to think
that that's how everyone is operating
you know I don't know if you like the
way that you guys live is in
contradiction to you know some paradigms
around culture but for you it's just
normal right right yeah yeah and so with
you you're abnormal also has a lot to do
with with performance how has how is
your view I mean your daily life
probably hasn't changed that much since
the since the pandemic but some things
have changed we were talking before we
started recording here there's some
inconveniences that have entered into
our our daily lives but have you noticed
some significant changes in your own
life yeah I mean first of all like my
life is remarkably unchanged like we
were talking before the podcast like I
you know I still can do my podcast
yes you know some of those episodes have
to be on zoom' now and we all have
opinions about that but I'm an introvert
by nature I work from home I podcast
from home I just like to go out on
trails and run by myself and ride my
bike and I can do all of those things
throughout all of this so my day-to-day
is remarkably unchanged versus you know
that of of a lot of people and I'm
incredibly grateful that I can still
pursue my living and you know support my
family and doing that but there's been
of course there's lots of changes I mean
there's been really positive aspects of
it like all our kids are home I have two
older boys who are 25 and 23 and they
were living in Echo Park they're
musicians you know doing the music thing
and they let go of their apartment and
move back home which has been really
great to have
them around and our two daughters you
know I have a mild my eldest daughter
who's 16 was going to a high school in
downtown and that really kind of split
our family up because it's so far from
our house we had to rent an apartment in
downtown LA and you know my wife and I
would take turns staying down there with
her
that's this rough different yeah it was
incredibly challenging but look you know
a lot of what I do is about like you
know pursue your hearts and you know and
and and you know try to try to breathe
life into that which gets you excited in
the morning and going to art school was
that for my daughter so I'm nothing if I
can't support that in her but that was
challenging so now she's everybody's at
home and so it's really brought our
family together
it's had challenges it's really hard for
my 16 year old daughter like for her to
be cut off from her social circles and
and have to do school on zoom'
especially when you're in art school and
she wants to be in the darkroom and she
wants to be painting and doing studio
time she can't do any of those things
you can't see your friends really really
super rough so the challenges have been
really in the parenting as much as
anything else but everything else with
respect to kind of my day-in day-out is
is kind of copacetic yeah I wonder about
us being in high school Josh like how we
would have reacted to high school being
cancelled so happy I know right
especially like I do feel a little bad
for people were graduating 2020 who
really wanted the pomp and circumstance
like I almost didn't go to our
graduation even really my mom was like
yeah you should probably go so I did but
yeah it wouldn't have mattered much to
me but I do see some new potential I
think richer kind of alluded this a
moment ago like now's the time to start
questioning everything and and I think
that's always true but especially now
maybe this gives us the space to start
question everything so whether it's
budgeting or stuff or simplifying our
our house what is essential it's asking
these questions because what we're
really asking is how do I want to move
forward do I want to move forward acting
and behaving how I did in the past it
was that working for me and what you're
learning through this actually is yes
what you were doing was working
really well for you by and large and
Ryan and I have learned that as well but
I think what a lot of people are
beginning to learn is like oh no maybe
maybe the way I was behaving with my my
budget or with with the way I was
allocating my time at work or with my
relationships maybe I need to start
questioning those things yeah I think
that a close cousin of minimalism is
essentialism you know in the Venn
diagram those two things overlap oh yeah
considerably and in this moment of
forced repose we're all being compelled
to look in the mirror and take stock and
inventory of those things that are
working and those things that are not
and with that is this conversation
around essentialism what is essential
and we have an opportunity to shed and
let go of those things that aren't
working because we're forced to stop
everything in this arrested state is now
under review right and that's cool yeah
because we can really understand that
those things that we thought were so
important now that we don't have we've
learned to live without and and I think
it's it's inherent in all of us to start
going whoa did I really need that thing
that I thought that I did I've gone
without it for this amount of time so
maybe I can let that go and I think that
that's what the new abnormal is all
about right when we begin to you know
step back into the world we're already
seeing that to some extent but you know
what do we want that to look like and I
think really seizing this moment to get
clarity on that is is the huge
opportunity I don't want anybody to miss
yeah it's interesting like the worst
thing that could happen is if everything
just went back to normal after all this
yeah yeah I would we got some questions
here today let's start with Kristen in
Long Beach California I've been told
that vision boards really help when it
comes to manifesting the things that you
really want and goal-setting bringing in
as a physical the challenge is I feel
like every time I look at them they look
cluttered to me and I really don't want
to have to cut through a million
magazines and also I feel like Pinterest
is kind of a dark hole like a rabbit
hole so what is it that you recommend
for putting something up in your face
cool spaces neat and focused and also
allows for the positive energy to come
through and be open to maybe the
universe delivering something positive
and even better than what it is that I'm
focused on manifesting so rich obviously
Ryan and I can talk about what we do but
I'm really interested in what you do in
terms of prioritizing the things that
you want to do whether you call it a
vision or a vision board or or just
tasks that you want to complete yeah how
do you stay focused I think that's what
she's really asking right well I think a
vision board is a great idea but it's
meaningless unless you have clarity
about what it is that you're actually
trying to actualize in your life right
you can put up tons of pictures that
inspire you in different ways and
there's nothing wrong with that that's a
cool thing to do but if you're not
actually clear within yourself about
that very thing that you're trying to
accomplish
I don't know how meaningful or valuable
that is and you know I've been doing
this my whole life beginning back when I
was like 14 15 years old as a swimmer I
used to put my goal I used to write my
goal time in like huge block letters and
I put it on my mirror in my bathroom and
above my bed on like a cork board so I
would it would be the first thing and I
would see when I would wake up in the
morning and the last thing I would see
before I went to bed at night and I
think you know what that reinforces is
is you know this is the thing I'm
working towards I want to be able to
swim this fast this time and the more
you see it and the more its reinforced
in your psyche the more you begin to
believe in the possibility of
actualizing that so I think just a few
items that really represent or symbolize
that thing you're trying to manifest are
important to have them kind of in your
sphere of you know vision at important
times throughout the day is is like a
really important thing to do and you
know what I do now I mean I'm pretty
clear on what I need and I'm a very
self-motivated person so I don't need to
cut out pictures from magazines to
remind me of that but you know I keep I
keep lists I'm like you know but next to
mine on my desk of these are the things
that I need to do today and I kind of
wake up and go to sleep
you know aware of what it is that I'm
trying to do
now it's just it's natural for me so I
don't need those cues but I think a lot
of people do and I think it's a good
practice to build that into your life
yeah you establish the habit in a way so
that you the the vision board is
effectively irrelevant to you but it
might be a great way for someone to
establish that habit now Ryan I like the
idea of kind of what rich is alluding to
here the having a vision board but with
one thing on it right that's a very
minimalist vision board
it's kind of what Ryan and I do in a way
we as the minimalist we tend to work on
one major project a year like we're
trying to finish up this documentary
which is supposed to be done about three
and a half years ago and and so it's
been postponed so we're actually working
on our vision board right now has two
things on it it's that documentary in
our next book which is done and we're
just going through new drafts now but
everything else we do tends to serve
these main projects these vision yeah
but these things that we have a vision
of completing and if it doesn't serve
that we have to get good at at saying no
now rich you're very good at saying no
to things I think I mean actually later
on I have I have a cue just said no to
that Brazilian Jujitsu with no it was
good knows good oh man you know what I
hear you saying rich which i think is
brilliant you're saying first like get
clear on what you want second find a way
to remind yourself of that thing that
you want and then the third part which
is the most important part even with a
vision board you got to take action like
without the action none of that's going
to happen yeah
so but I'll tell you when Kristin asked
her question I caught something in there
where she said you know I want to do a
vision board but I want to take the time
to do the vision board yeah and I would
urge Kristen if she really thinks a
vision board is going to add value to
her life like take the action and do it
like you got to take action with
something well there's goals there
strategies and there's tactics so you
have the big goal like I want to
complete this documentary or I want this
documentary to be a success then there's
the strategy which is all the things
that need to happen in order to serve
that goal and the tactics are the things
that you need to do every day so
bifurcating those and then breaking it
down into the daily things that need to
be accomplished every day that serve
that goal I think is the you know kind
of the systemic systematic way of doing
that yeah love that yeah I agree
and to echo your sort of to-do list I
also don't have a to-do list because I
find I'm very OCD and if I have a to-do
list I will put things on it just like
and cross them off yeah there's there's
something like that and so I'm making
these false accomplishments writing down
the to-do lists deludes you into
thinking that you've actually done
something right
right a to-do list right I have two
lists and they're both on my Apple note
so it's on my computer or on my phone I
have a today list and so things that you
know what are the most important things
that I need to accomplish today and then
I have a some day list right not and
quite often those are things that I know
I'm not going to do tomorrow or
immediately but they're there it's a
vision board of sorts where it's like
it's an idea it's an idea catcher in a
way where I'm like okay that might be
something I want to work on and I I
revisit that someday list all the time
and I'm quite often just going in there
and deleting things I'm actually never
going to do that or wow that was a
really good idea maybe I'm going to get
back to that now that I have the
opportunity to do so so I tell you what
Kristin I would love to send you a
couple tickets to our tour we're headed
to Los Angeles which is close enough to
Long Beach or we could send you to the
OC stop if you wanted to go to our
Orange County stop as well we got a
bunch of tour dates coming up the
minimalists comm a slash tour we have
some special guests some special musical
guests we're gonna do a live podcast and
so much more of less the minimalist calm
slash tour but Shawn if you could reach
out to Kristen give her a couple tickets
to either one of those events that are
coming up in November and by the way if
we're not coming to a city near you you
can just sign up for our email list if
you like and we'll be happy to notify
you if we are coming to a city near you
our next question is from Kara in
Minnesota I had a question about the
diet and exit
sighs I'm just curious if you have an
updated version from what you wrote
about in your books and if you've
changed things or if you're still doing
the same workouts and eating the same
this is a fascinating topic because it's
one that I continue to evolve on based
on different health struggles that I've
had over the last few years but rich I'd
rather talk to you about about this
because you we did a whole episode with
you about food and you talked about how
you were sort of overweight and
unhealthy and then modified your diet
but I imagine you continue to modify
depending on your circumstances how has
this pandemic shined a light on that for
you but also for the people that listen
to your podcasts and our people starting
to ask different questions about food
right now I think there's a an enhanced
interest in food because everyone's at
home right now so they're not going to
restaurants and they're not doing
takeout I mean there's some takeout of
course but I've noticed for myself that
I've taken a lot more joy in the
preparation of meals at home especially
having the kids around we make a big
event out of it and that's been really
great and I've noticed the impact in how
it makes me feel to eat home-cooked food
that's infused with love you know I'm a
busy guy and I'm not like might we have
all these cookbooks but my wife is the
cook right like when she's downtown with
mathis our daughter and I'm at home I'm
getting veggie burritos at Chipotle like
a couple of times a week like you know
I'm not perfect in that regard I mean I
have been I've been plant-based for 13
years
and I've continued to kind of iterate on
that I've remained plant-based this
entire time but I have noticed that the
quality of my nutrition and my attention
to it has has increased since since
we've been sequestered and I've noticed
how that makes me feel and I think
that's good and I think when we're at
home we we do have the opportunity to be
a little bit more mindful about what
we're putting in our bodies and I think
right now one of the things that gets a
little bit
lost in this conversation around
coronavirus is the importance of
maintaining our immune response and that
is directly tied to diet and exercise we
have got to be taking care of ourselves
right now so that in the event that we
come into contact with the virus we're
in the best you know position we can
possibly be to combat that yeah so so
your diet probably hasn't changed you're
still plant-based but your exercise
routine has that changed at all
I've definitely been training more now
that at home because my schedule has
freed up like I'm not you know driving
into Hollywood to do podcasts with the
minimalist all the time so so yeah I
have I have I have definitely dialed
things up with with my training and then
what I find is when I'm engaged in my
training and I say training as distinct
from exercising because I think there's
a difference like you can go out and
exercise training for me means Barratt
means being very intentional about what
I'm doing every workout that I have has
a purpose and that purpose is directed
at a goal and the more intentional I am
about that training and the kind of
mindfulness that I bring to why I'm
doing what I'm doing on a daily basis
that in turn makes me more invested in
my nutrition so as I start to get fitter
and feel better in my body then I want
to eat the right foods and I'm less
likely to crash on the couch and just
you know plow my flour my head into a
bag of chips or whatever it is I'm
curious if Mariah and I my wife and I we
have recently been ordering like meat
I know you don't eat meat so I even said
that but what we've been ordering our
meat from like a very witnesses every
time but we also do make people I know
but we also did well it's funny because
we were in San Francisco the first time
he was with us and I was like
recommending this really well source
meat it was like what are you doing our
[ __ ] was like what you doing man anyway
rich I'm sorry but with our veggies we
do the same thing and I'm curious how do
you get your veggies like are you going
to a grocery store on a regular basis or
like do you do any type of delivery
service no delivery service I mean we
live close to an era Juan oh yeah we end
up spending a lot of money on food to
get organic
food one thing I have started doing
though which is really fun everyone's
talking about like making sourdough
bread right now yeah at home but it's
like you know I started sprouting I had
my friend Doug Evans on the podcast who
just wrote this book called the sprout
book it's all about mung beans or any
kind of it's crazy like I thought I knew
about like when you think about sprouts
you just think about those little
plastic containers when you go to the
grocery store and they're crazy
expensive for these little garnishes
that you put on your salad or array your
sandwich yeah but actually you can make
them at home for like pennies mm-hmm and
it only takes a couple days and these
jars you just like kind of rinse these
seeds and they grow like miraculously
over two to three days and they're
unbelievably nutritious and you could
just eat them like it's weird you just
eat like handfuls of them but they're
actually really filling really and I've
noticed how much better I feel and it's
just like a fun little project because
I've had aspirations of you know
creating a garden at home and if there's
anybody who should be growing their own
food it's me we have all this land and
but we're busy and I just we've taken a
couple stabs at it and never works and
like I just get distracted but this is
like a really simple easy thing to do
love it that allows you to kind of make
your own food for like no money at all
and and really take care of you're
looking at this because I've heard of
sprouting and how good it is for you and
I Mariah and I love like doing little
projects where we grow stuff at home but
uh yeah awesome in Rhonda patrick has a
good episode on her podcast found my
fitness about a bell I think broccoli
sprouts in particular but a lot of
sprouting there's an issue yeah okay but
you can do all kinds of them we've done
mung beans at our house before yeah yeah
but actually Sean if you can find that
put a link to that in the show notes the
the Rhonda Patrick episode but she
really goes into the details of all the
the science and the data behind that
richness the one I just did with oh my
show too or he goes into all that as
well oh that's great even better lets us
put a link to that in the show notes the
rich roll podcast aptly named rich I
find that I agree with what you what
you're saying here is I've had it's not
that I've had more time I still have 24
hours in a day but I have had more focus
on I wouldn't call it training I'm not
training for anything in particular but
just my overall health so diet and
exercise in particular the diet thing
it's not a priest ripoli different from
me either but we are doing almost
everything at home at this point and
what I'm finding there is I feel better
because they're not sneaking ingredients
in like I can go to a restaurant and get
a supposedly healthy meal but all of a
sudden has your refined oils in it as
opposed to olive oil some msg sprinkles
right that food right yeah right but at
home I actually know what what you know
it's we are using olive oil and not the
canola oil or whatever it might be and
same with with exercise I have found
myself well I've found myself on the
peloton a lot more yeah I fell off the
peloton a few weeks ago it was a very
sad day dude
alright quick story have know about Josh
and I we were in Hawaii like back when
we're in the corporate world we had one
like a trip for me and you know best
yeah best salesman or whatever so we go
to the top of this attend Maui we go to
the top of this volcano Mount Holly oh
yeah and we do the bike ride the Sun we
do the sunrise and then we do the bike
ride down and it's funny cuz there's
like a long line of us with bikes and
the instructor he was like Joshua's like
I don't know I'm kind of uncomfortable
to bike though I said I don't really
know how to ride a bike yeah and he's
like what it's like what he's like well
he's like well you know if you're too
bad I'll just put you in the front of
the pack he's like but I've never had to
put a man in the front of the pack we
were riding fraternity sexes
yeah incredibly sexist if we're riding
for like 10 minutes and he was he
stopped the whole line he was like Josh
I'm gonna need you to go ahead and come
up front I'm Lyle I know yeah anyway I
found myself like just exercising a lot
more being a lot more intentional every
day like this morning I got up and
lifted some weights thankfully I or I
bout some weights a few months before
this whole thing hit apparently they're
really hard to get now but I actually
want to talk to you about your daily
routine here in a bit actually let's do
that on the run out of time here we'll
do that on the maximal but Kara I want
to give you a free ebook
it's called 16 rules for living with
less I think you'll enjoy that you can
find over at the minimalists comm slash
rulebook well anyone can find it
over there as well thanks your question
Ryan with Thomism you know what time it
is it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages text
your questions and comments to nine
three seven two zero two four six five
four yes indeed those texts literally go
to both of our phones and we personally
answer as many of them as we can
especially during this hold quarantine
we've answered almost every single one
of them rich during the lightning round
you know this what we try to answer a
question with a short share of a less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes no not really we just monitor
out of it because Shawn will tweeze out
something and make it beautiful he puts
it in the show notes people can copy and
share our answers on social media if
they like you can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place by the way
minimal Maxim's com Ryan Shawn's got a
question for us not this Shawn but Shawn
with his name spelled incorrectly yes
and Sen John how do you find the
strength to keep pushing when it all
starts breaking down so rich I was
thinking about this because there's a a
part in our new book a lot of people use
things called rebuilding after a
breakdown in fact the a couple
paragraphs before that is from a
different section called the theology of
pain and it kind of talks about
suffering and getting to solutions
so my pithy answer is actually from from
that book it's sometimes it takes a
breakdown to experience a breakthrough I
think we all recognize this you
certainly recognize this in your own
life you're at a point where you around
age 40 I believe it was right we're not
happy with with your current existence
no tell me well I had a listen you know
I had a I've had I've had a couple like
moments of reckoning they tend to
convict they tend to come at decade
intervals in my life but the first was
you know I met my maker with drugs and
alcohol and he destroyed my life and I
had a moment of clarity and made some
changes and got sober and that was 22
years ago and a handful of days actually
that that happened and then yeah inching
up on 40 50 pounds overweight workaholic
just you know how to he'll scare and
realized once again
and that although I'd been on a
spiritual path since I got sober that
there was still a lot of work to be done
and that's when I rearranged my
relationship with food and fitness and
kind of reinvented myself once again and
I think you know to answer your question
you know these moments of breakdown and
destruction it goes back to opportunity
the way that we opened up this podcast
these are opportunities so we can we can
dwell in the misery of you know our
lives getting stripped away or we can
recognize that this is happening for us
rather than to us and to you know seize
on to it in order to make these changes
that you know our being called to make
like if your life isn't functioning and
you're finding yourself in a state of
despair there's a reason for that so
what can we what can we mind from that
experience to grow and I think we have a
tendency to evaluate our circumstances
from a very myopic immediate point of
view like this is bad this is happening
you know this is happening to me right
now and it's not fair and it sucks and
that may be true but we have to
telescope out and understand that life
may be short but it's also kind of long
and what may suck in the moment may be
the greatest gift you've ever been given
and I know in my own personal
experiences that I've been in situations
where I thought this is the absolute
worst thing that could have ever
happened to me and now I look back on
those as the greatest gifts I've ever
been given and I'm very grateful for
them so my hope and my wish for anybody
who is feeling like they're in that
place right now is to understand that
you know the the power to change your
life resides within you and if you can
recognize that and begin to take tiny
steps every single day that you will
find yourself in a very different
position and perhaps you can look back
on this experience with gratitude yeah
that's not 140 characters though brevity
is not my strength we'll put it on
Facebook yeah
podcast on will make it look really
Facebook that
my pithy answer is this keep tally of
how many times you get up not how many
times you fall and you know really it's
just kind of saying what you're saying
is like look at when you get knocked
down when you think the world is falling
apart look at it as an opportunity to
rise above and I know that's what I do
it's it's weird like when I have 2 or 3
hours nights of sleep and I have to do
something that the next day there's like
something I can light up inside of me
maybe it's just my a DD extroverted ness
where I'm like no Nicodemus you got this
and it's almost like I can do better
than if I had like a 10-hour night's
sleep
so again just looking for opportunities
to get up and take some massive action I
think I've learned over the last two
years for me personally is that the
health matters so much more than we give
a credit for you but the Confucius line
is that a healthy man wants 10,000
things a sick man once but one and in
the new book the thing I sort of talked
about there is that if you're healthy
you're already living the dream and
that's the thing that I would try to
communicate to Sean here is think about
that everything else whether it's your
possessions your status your riches your
validation it's window dressing and if
you are unhealthy you're going if you're
suffering through something this is the
richest point also the pain is temporary
and I think we don't feel that in the
moment in the moment it feels like the
the suffering is going to last forever
but of course on a long enough timeline
everything is ephemeral right everything
is temporary this suffering is useful
also yes you know and I also think it's
important for people to be patient I
think there's this urgency and the sense
of immediacy that our culture expects
like what you're like oh you're gonna be
the overnight millionaire or you're
gonna change your life on a dime and you
know I'm sure if if someone was to
Google your story or my stand I know for
a fact with my story you'll read these
articles and it makes it look like you
just snapped your fingers and changed
everything overnight and it wasn't like
that it's not a linear thing it's up
down it takes time and I think people
overestimate what they can do in six
months or a year and wildly
underestimate what they can do in ten
years and you know as the elder
statesman here I'm 53 years old I can
tell you that that those changes are
possible but they're about those little
things that you do every day and being
patient and kind to yourself and
understanding that you shouldn't be
evaluating your progress on a
moment-to-moment basis like understand
that these things you know evolve very
gradually you know yeah all right before
we get into our listener tips and our
added value segment today Ryan you're
really gonna like this added value it is
very appropriate for our current times
but before we get to that and before you
get to those listener tips and tricks it
looks like we've got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how
can someone be a minimalist when there's
always the urge to accumulate more gear
or tech for hobbies and athletic
endeavors now rich has well a bunch of
gear is much a tech hobbies and also
tech endeavors and of course athletic
endeavors he's probably the most
athletic person that we know stay tuned
to hear all his brand names that he
wears what watch is that rich well I got
to find out but only later this week
we're also gonna discuss veganism and a
plant-based diet the rich is on we're
talking about work-life balance we're
gonna talk about OCD and perfectionism
we're gonna talk about lifespan versus
health span we're gonna talk about
Rich's routine you know he sleeps
outside and we're gonna talk about why
and really the benefits of that we're
also gonna talk about Rich's aggressive
email autoresponder and Ryan I know that
this is something he does the you and I
might be able to get some benefit from
truly inspiring it really is all that
and a million more questions for Rich
roll and if you want to hear all that
listen to this week's maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast and it's
just a couple bucks and it's the most
honest way for the minimalists to earn
an income because as you know we don't
believe in advertisements we think
advertisements suck so the money we make
where we only make money if you find
valuing and support what we create head
on over to the minimalists column slash
support and subscribe to get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app Ryan what else you got for us this
week here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out hey guys this is Angela calling from
Minneapolis calling with just a couple
of tips I've been going through and
decluttering and trying to minimize my
rather large 4,000 plus square foot 5
bedroom 4 bath house while I dream of
moving to a smaller space and as I'm
going through my house I'm trying to
look at it as if I'm moving so I'm going
through closet by closet drawer room by
room and taking everything out and just
trying to look at things and say okay am
I going to bring these with to my next
property instead of thinking well I
might need these someday for this big
old house that I have right now it's
helped me get rid of a lot of things to
look at it that way so that when I do
get ready to move I don't have to go
through things I can just pack them and
know that everything that I'm bringing
with me is things that I will actually
use and that bring value to me the other
thing that I have found really helpful
because I'm the type of person that when
I look at material things I see dollar
signs I see the money that I have spent
on them which is really hard for me I'm
a huge donating person I used to spend
thousands of dollars every year
clearance hunting and consuming you know
the thrill of the hunt finding the good
deals to buy things that I could donate
to Toys for Tots or local animal rescues
and then I realized I can't afford to do
that so I have stopped doing that and
donated most of the items that I had
intended to donate but when I look
around at my own possessions I see
dollar signs on everything so I have a
hard time letting go of things that I
feel like have value Facebook
marketplace has been an absolute
God sent for me I have sold thousands of
dollars worth of things that I don't
want and what I found works really well
for me is I will take a group of items I
will list them all on Facebook
marketplace and then I'll pack them in a
donation box if they don't sell within
one to two weeks or whenever I get
around to dropping them off at Goodwill
then they get donated and I delete them
off of Marketplace but at least I feel
like I've given myself a chance to sell
those things and to get money for them
which is a huge hang up for me letting
go of things that I feel have value and
I feel like that has worked really well
because if they don't sell within a
couple weeks chances are they're not
going to sell and then I pack them up
and put them aside in the garage so that
they're out of my house they're dealt
with and then I just load up my car
every couple weeks and drop off boxes
and let go of those things it's almost
like once I put them into the box I let
go at that point one way or the other so
I would highly suggest that people try
and sell their items to get money to pay
down their debt like I am but don't hold
on to them forever you have to set a
timeline to let them go this is a
message for Han the woman who lost her
son and is having a difficult time
getting rid of his things and let me say
is the father of a 14 year old myself I
cannot even fathom a greater loss than
the loss of a child and I imagine it
would be extremely difficult to even
comprehend the thought of letting go of
his things out of fear that somehow you
will be letting go at him but let me ask
you Anne if your son's spirit could
return to this earth for even 10 minutes
time what do you believe he would return
to his desk his clothes his things no my
guess is he would return to you to his
mom to his loved ones because that is
where he resides now not in his
possessions therefore it would be my
humble suggestion that you have someone
you love and trust calm and gently
remove and repurpose these things and in
so doing you will discover that you are
not removing your son
for that would be impossible you will
always be his mother and for as long as
you were destined to roam this earth he
will always remain in your heart in your
memories and in your very soul but maybe
just maybe in repurposing his things you
will be able to remove even if only a
fraction some of the tremendous pain and
loss associated with his death
alright y'all thanks again to rich roll
for joining us today check out his
podcast wherever you listen to podcast
is called the rich roll podcast you can
also find him online if he just google
rich roll you'll find him or you can
find his website as well we'll put a
link to that in the show notes for our
added value this week Ryan J us J s
endora he has a new album out and he is
the singer-songwriter from Minneapolis
and he reminds me of a little bit of Bob
Dylan may he rest in peace
[Laughter]
to soon no J a Sundara he is this really
talented singer-songwriter but he wrote
an entire album about the quarantine and
so like there's a song on there about
not being able to pay rent on time
there's a song about loving someone from
six feet away and it's it's a really
good album but it's also very timely but
at the same time if you listen to it at
the first pass by the way the album is
called tales of isolation and we'll put
a link to it in the show notes the first
pass it sounds very timeless because of
the dylan-esque nature of it actually he
sounds like Bob Dylan if Bob Dylan could
sing because Jess and Dora can sing
really really really well but there's
this folks Eve folk and roll sort of
feel to it anyway it feels both timeless
and very timely which is one of my
favorite things from this album is like
I think we can listen to a ten years
from now it would still feel applicable
and metaphorical but right now it feels
so literal because it is a real quick
for right here right now here is one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalist I teach a writing class it's
currently closed so you can't sign up
for it good luck trying but I do have
something free for you right now if
you're waiting to get into that
writing class or if you're not waiting
to get into the writing class you just
want something free to help you improve
your writing it's a free ebook called 11
ways to write better and you can
download that right now over at how to
write better or give us 11 tips that
I've learned that have certainly helped
me write better and I think those tips
will help you out as well eleven ways to
write that are over at how to write
better org you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows at the
minimalists comm slash tour you can find
a city near you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists com comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash The
Mentalist and if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm you'll
never receive spam or junk or
advertisements from us but you will
receive our podcast show notes also our
simple Sunday emails whenever we send
those and feel it here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
yeah we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]